hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled code 19 infection
mechanism tools for testing and
therapeutic antibody development this
webinar is part of the ongoing
coronavirus webinar series
I am Kaylee baka blabbers and I will be
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by gem script to
learn more visit Jen script comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is in fact we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask question box and clicks
then we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box located in the
far left of your screen as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain upends I
now present today's speakers dr. sean
taylor and dr. manzou king dr. taylor
holds a PhD and an MBA from McGill
University and has spent the past ten
years publishing articles providing
seminars workshops and training videos
to help the global scientific community
as sheep excellent data from Western
blotting
qpcr and digital PCR experiments he has
managed teams of field application
scientists in Canada for over a decade
who have helped thousands of scientists
achieved their research goals in his
current role as North American FIS
manager for Jen script he leads a
dedicated team to continue the tradition
of providing pertinent and timely
information to help the scientific
community overcome research hurdles to
accelerate the production of
high-quality publishable data
cost-effectively dr. Mann Zoo Kane
received her PhD from the University of
California Los v's with
education focusing on the impact of
combinatorial therapy on the evolution
of drug resistance dr. King is a senior
scientist of antibody research group at
Jen script robota
she is in charge of the single b-cell
screening platform for antibody drug
discovery for a complete biography on
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr. Taylor
dr. King welcome you may now begin your
presentation
America this video will cover a tutorial
to explain the mechanism infection rate
and tools for monitoring the novel
coronavirus 2019 other synonyms that are
used routinely in the scientific
community for coronavirus to 2019 as
kovat 19 Tsarskoe VIII - - so ii corona
virus that causes SARS and then 2019 and
Covey's so all of these are synonyms
that that people use interchangeably for
the same coronavirus that initiated late
2019 in china so the first step in
discussing any virus is looking at its
structure and i'm doing and i'm going to
do this very briefly there are a lot of
articles published which which describe
in much more detail and and much more
eloquently the structure of the virus
but to just briefly overview the key
features in kovat 19 are this spike
glycoprotein this is very important and
I'll discuss this in the next slide
there are a number of glycoproteins that
are on the surface of the corona virus
and they all play different roles and
functions there's also the nucleo capsid
proteins which are inside the nuclear
envelope of inside the the the coat of
the virus and then there's also RNA and
the RNA is used by the virus to
replicate itself once it is engulfed is
is is endocytosed into the host cell so
how do we how does the virus transmitted
how does what is the mechanism of action
of Kovach 19 so this image is an image
of the virus and this image is an image
of the host cell so kovat 19 likes to
bind by its spike glycoproteins so this
protein here the spike glycoprotein is
how the virus binds to the host cell and
it right and this spike glycoprotein
very specifically recognizes on host
cells
this blue protein here it's not blue
it's just color blue here and that's
called angiotensin converting enzyme to
AC e2 so this has been identified as a
key SARS coronavirus receptor and it
plays a protective role in SARS
so in SARS pathogenesis and this was
also published recently in nature by Zhu
P at all so the spike glycoprotein very
specifically binds to the AC e to
receptor on the host cells and then the
host cells endocytosis the virus inside
the cell and then the virus replicates
itself within the cell and when it
replicates it eventually leaves the cell
and you can see the virus here kind of
exocytosis and it's coming out of the
cell after it's replicated itself and
now we have more virus made from the
host cell now a c2 is important to
understand because this receptor is
provides protection from deep lung
injury so it's in that it's in the cells
deep inside the lung so when kovat 19
binds inside deep in the line to AC to
the virus and the receptor so both of
these the virus and the receptor itself
are internalized into the cell so you
lose these receptors as the virus binds
to them and and takes them inside the
cell the reduction of a c2 can
ultimately lead to pneumonia by a
variety of mechanisms so I'm not gonna
go through all this but a c2 provides a
protective role and we need a c2 to
protect ourselves from a variety of
problems that can happen inside the lung
a c2 that receptor is not only in the
deep lung where where we see symptoms of
the virus with pneumonia and all these
things but we also it's also expressed
highly in the heart
intestine and kidney which can also
potentially lead to illness in these
tissues with kovat 19 infection so
there's a lot of work being done on this
to assess how kovat 19 infection affects
not just the lungs which are where we
know the major symptoms are but also in
the other in these other tissues spike
glycoprotein which is here in red
contains 2 subunits
it contains the s-1 subunit in yellow
and this is the unit that binds to AC 2
and then it contains an s2 subunit so
these are important when we talk about
detection of the virus and we'll talk
about this in the coming slides ok so
now let's talk about trends transmission
rate and the requirement to monitor the
disease so with viruses we always use a
term called the Arnott okay we've seen
this in movies pandemic and other movies
so they are not is is the transmission
effectively the transmission rate and
for kovat 19 a recent study was was
performed in China published in the
lancet journal by by Kraske at all and
they determined that without social
distance in so with just the virus
running rampant through through China
through Wuhan that the are not was
approximately 2 so this is without any
any social distance in any laws in place
to prevent people from interacting with
each other so with an on out of 2 what
that means is that a single individual
can infect two individuals so imagine
one individual infects 2 and then those
two individuals affect two more people
and so on and so forth so you end up
with this exponential increase this
doubling of infected people each time
the new infected people interact with
other individuals and the rate of
infection is approximately six days so
every
six days there's a doubling of the
amount of people that are infected if
they're if there are no rules or laws in
place to prevent people from interacting
with each other so the interpretation
therefore would be that without social
distancing without any rules in place
one person can infect two people over a
six day period and the following six
days those people each infect two more
people for a total of four people and
within two months that single person
that started off the infection will lead
to a thousand people being infected so
that's pretty serious
because that that that you know causes a
large dramatic increase in the amount of
infection in the society what they also
did though kershaw at all because then
China implemented social distancing
right they closed Wuhan borders they
made people stay in the homes and then
they determined that the are not with
social distancing was was one so this
means that with social distancing one
person only affects one other person
over six days so within the same
two-month period there isn't this
exponential increase of infection there
will only be a few people infected over
a two-month period and effectively the
virus can can just be alleviated can be
can be rectified by social distancing so
that's what that's what this study
showed so this underlines the
requirement to monitor the number of
global cases because we need to be able
to assess the effect of social
distancing on this are not number
because if they are not is one or lower
than were then were effectively
eradicating the virus we're effectively
keeping the virus under control in
society but if as soon as the Arnon is
above one then we have then we can
implement have this exponential increase
of the virus infection can run rampant
through society and affect our
healthcare systems and our economy and
everything okay so so Diagnostics what
do we have there are there a variety of
Diagnostics out there there are disease
Diagnostics and
there are virus detection methodologies
so for disease Diagnostics these
complete be as simple as routine blood
tests for increased
liver enzymes muscle enzymes myoglobin
so a variety of markers that are in the
blood that would denote infection
they're also chest imaging so you can
look at multiple patchy shadows interest
interstitial changes so this is all
lung-lung effects so you can see
pathology and the lungs from viral
infection now of course these blood
tests and chest imaging are quite
expensive because it requires going to a
hospital nurses doctors equipment all
required to be able to examine you there
are other ways to look at these are more
molecular methods so nucleic acid
detection and this is this is one that
that's that's used a lot and was used a
lot for corona virus so the first step
in the process of nucleic acid detection
is determining determining the nucleic
acid sequence of the virus itself and
that was already done in China so they
determined the sequence and by knowing
the sequence of the RNA inside the virus
then they can develop kits to detect the
RNA by a technology called real-time PCR
or isothermal PCR so these are these are
methods that are very quick and easy
they they require taking a blood sample
from the patient into a Rasputin's that
are secreted from from from patients and
then they can detect whether the viral
RNA is is in their secreted fluids and
that would indicate infection and it's a
very sensitive test this this permits
you to detect infection very early there
are serology detection methodologies as
well and this is this is related to when
our own immune system starts to battle
the virus so when our immune system
battles the virus we generate antibodies
against the virus itself and those
antibodies
start to circulate in the blood and
those antibodies can be detected in a
variety of means one of them is called
Eliza and those kits can be can be made
and then used to detect circulating
antibodies that we've generated the
advantage of serology detection is that
you can detect the antibodies even after
the virus has been eradicated by the
immune system so you'll know if a person
has bit has already been infected with
the nucleic acid detection once the
virus has been eradicated there there
will be no more nucleic acids no more
RNA from the virus in the secreted
fluids and you won't know if the
person's been infected so timing for
molecular tests are important therefore
and for testing antibodies in inpatient
blood it's a good choice for rapid
simple and highly sensitive diagnosis of
the virus but again antibodies for the
virus are only made after infection has
happened so it can take several days up
to five to ten days for antibodies to be
generated so it's widely accepted that
IgM if we look here on a timeline we can
see that the very initial detection
methodology immediately after infection
would be the viral RNA and that would be
by qPCR so if you really want to know
quickly if someone's been infected early
on in the infection then qpcr is the
best way to go to detect the viral RNA
that's circulating because there's going
to be a lot of virus in that patient at
that stage but then as time goes by we
generate antibodies and then we can
detect these antibodies later on so
after Vyra after the virus has gone away
then we can still detect these
antibodies because these antibodies stay
with us essentially forever so that we
can combat the virus the next time
there's a there's a
outbreak so it's widely accepted that
IgM provides the first line of defense
during viral infections and then IgG is
a later response even later after
infection that can also be detected so
these are antibodies that can be that
can be detected post infection nucleic
acid detection for SARS Co V only gives
a positive result when the virus is
still present as I mentioned and is also
dependent on sampling the appropriate
tissues of fluids remember this is a
deep-lying infection so it's important
to swab way back in the throat to assure
that the shedding of the virus has come
out of the deep lung to the back of the
throat
it may not be in the saliva early on in
the infection and it may not be in other
body fluids so it's it can if the
sampling is not done properly then you
can easily get some false negative
results with with nucleic acid detection
and qPCR antibody tests can confirm the
infection so that so they can be used as
a complementary test in case the
sampling wasn't done properly in case
there's false negatives the antibody
tests can confirm infection and and
would give a positive result even if a
PCR test is of a suspected case is
negative so I'm not going to go through
this slide in great detail this is just
just to show that the but the virus was
sequenced and there are a variety of
targets in the virus genes that have
been used to make kits for qpcr to
detect the virus ORF 1a b e and n these
are all regions of the viral genome that
are being used to detect the virus by
nucleic acid detection so gen script has
come up with with a few kits to do this
we have a one-step kit which will detect
as I mentioned before the ORF 1a B n and
E so these kids are all available with
primers so this is very quick easy
detection of the virus available to
detect the presence or absence of virus
early on in infection
there are also duplex assays where where
these kits can can detect two of these
targets in one test in one sample so
this is great if the patient has very
little sample or if we're very early on
the infection we don't have very much
sample so we wanted to check more than
one or just as a cross test to assure
that if one is positive that the other
target is positive so that where we get
a much more much more strength in the
confirmation that the virus is there and
again these kits are available from Jen
script for serology diagnosis we've also
generated some Eliza kits to detect the
IgG and IgM and these kits are on the
market that are available they're all
here for looking at IgG and IgM analysis
from patient blood samples so the
antibodies are circulating in the blood
it's a simple blood test and then you
can detect either a weak positive or
strong positive dependent on the point
at which the infection occurred so this
is a good way to cross-reference testing
with qPCR so why why should we use
serology tests as well as qPCR because
qPCR sounds so great because you can
detect it early well the reason why you
want to use serology tests as well is
because we want to trace the overall
infection within the population from
those who have recovered remember Q PCR
will not detect the virus if it's not in
the blood stream and for recovered
patients there will be no virus left but
the anti
bodies against the virus will be there
so serology tests are important so that
we can understand how many people have
actually been infected so they can be
used to also confirm infections if the
qpcr test has been done then the
serology tests can be used to also help
confirm that that patient is in fact
positive and it's it's good as an
accurate and simple point of care test
because qPCR requires several steps and
kits and equipment serology tests are
much more simple they're easier to run
so in this case we had several patients
that were tested and all we're showing
here is data from a standard curve so
this is this is a recombinant s1 protein
that was diluted just to show where how
sensitive the kid can go how much
dilution you can use before you're able
before you're not able to get a good
signal from the Eliza test and with
actual patient samples from plasma we
recommend to to not go below a one in
1,000 dilution of the plasma samples to
get a good signal for the IgG and IgM
tests one in a hundred is actually even
better but you could go as low as one a
thousand and still get a signal that is
above the healthy controls so these are
the healthy control signals so the
entire spectrum of proteins and assays
for kovat 19 are assembled on the Jen
script website and click here at Jen
script comm slash virus underscore
antigens and here we've assembled the
full list of available proteins and
assays the N protein all of the S
proteins and some fusion proteins all
available or very very soon to be
available as well as the ACE 2 receptor
protein antibodies and the 2 Eliza
detection kits which are currently
available so if you want to quickly
detect the Eliza kids are available and
for assembling assays all the proteins
are available on the website we also
have a services platform which can
provide customized proteins for
producing exotic assays or tests or
research so we have of course the qPCR
detection assay either single Plex or
duplex as well as plasmids and proteins
and antibodies for kovat 19 research
that can be customized to the desire of
whatever research or kits that you are
planning on producing so we hope that
you stay safe in this new age of social
distancing let's reduce that are not
down to 1 or lower so that we can move
on past kovat 19
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us today at the lab roots and
webinar series
my name is mental call I'm a senior
scientist at the end put a drug
discovery department at Jenks great
profile
today I'm going to talk to you about the
accelerator at Kobe 90 antibody
discovery with crispy single b-cell
technology first I'm going to talk to
you about the background of Kobe 19 and
that's I'm going to present you with
some of our newest data or results for
for the antibody discovery for Kobe 19
and lastly I'm gonna focus on the
single-cell screening for Kobe 19 Kobe
19 has developing to a global pandemic
that's affecting thousands if not
millions of lives globally by March 31st
the total confirmed cases reported by
the SCC at Johns Hopkins reaches over
seven hundred and eighty four thousand
and there are tremendous resources and
efforts are being important to
developing either vaccination for
protecting the general population of
Laura or therapeutic agents to treat
infected individuals there are seven
different major drug targets that can be
used for Kobe 19 the one that's probably
the most prominent or the most explored
is the spike protein which is on the
surface of the viral particle and it's
responsible for the interaction with the
h2 receptor on the host cell surface for
it for the subsequent viral entry and
there are the other drug targets include
the amyloid protein the membrane protein
the protease the nuclear capsid protein
the hemagglutinin ester is in the
helicase and there are also 16 on
structure proteins that can be targeted
as well but like I mentioned again the
spike proteus probably the ones that's
being the most explored so a three
different major and what a discovery
platforms which are hybridoma hybridoma
the ants body live
and we have both the human ieave library
the human synthetic library is under
it's being developed right now and then
also the lava naive library for
generating SDP or the single domain
buddy and our newest addition for our
abd platforms it's the single b-cell
screening platform adopting the the
beacon platform from Berkley lights and
we are utilizing all our all of our
platforms to to scrape for desirable
leads against Kobe 19 which have the
following three characteristics the
first is the ability to bind to spike
protein and the second is to block us
protein and h2 you know action and
lastly or ultimately to neutralize or
inhibit the Kobe 19 interactivity and on
this slide I'm presenting is some of our
newest results from the phage display
screening against Kobe 19 the target
that we use in is RVD ss1 protein or the
receptor binding domain of s1 protein
and we're screening against both our
human eye youth library and love and I
eat library the unique binder that we
got for human eye Viper is over 70 and
then we have about 48 sta these screen
from the lamina 8 library here where you
what I'm showing you is the fax result
for some Thea the the binders that we're
characterizing visually first we did an
RPG or the dose responses were for the
ec50 of our BT binding on the the h2 or
the h2 receptor expressed on the staple
cell line and we can see right here is
the partial blocking of of the
interaction or the binding between the
RBT and h2o unstable cell eyes so what's
and I'm highlighting some of the more
interesting results we have one lead
with a KD at the nano molar range that
has a very significant or substantial
blocking effect as well and suffer want
to some of the things that I want to
point out is we do have some binders
that that that has not that that has a
pretty pretty good walking in fat but on
the lights or results for the binding it
was not the best it was not our best
binder but it was it shows a very very
good unblocking effect which is in
concordance with some of the newest
results from other I guess researcher or
people as flower where you're the blocky
effects that that you that you might be
looking for may not be coming from your
best binder so that's just something to
keep in mind so moving on I'm gonna
focus on the single-cell screening for
Kobe 19 to give you an overview of our
chi-square Pro speed system from
immunization to recombinant MIB
production the shortest timeline that we
can achieve is 1/2 1/2 month with
express immunization which takes about 2
weeks and the general workflow involves
after realization the B cell will be
harvest and enriched for plasma cell and
those b-cell subset will be imported or
penned into the chip that's used for
screening and with various entry essays
including specificity affinity and
functionality and after we analyze the
results and pick our desirable lead the
export of the single B cell will be
exported into 96-well place and follow
that is the cDNA synthesis and
sequencing and recombinant and maybe
production and what I want to point out
right here is from B cell harvests who's
exporting the single B so
that you picked out of this process can
be finished within lesson day and
immediately you can see how valuable
this platform can be for developing
antibody leaves that are extremely
time-sensitive and this is a fully
automated efficient and comprehensive
platform to really accelerate your and
what a discovery the general workflow
involves three major steps first is to
import import your sample and then that
next is to assay and here we're showing
you the assay can be done in a motive no
multiplex
fashion where we can do multiple assets
same time or have different different
results are different readout before for
one singular as a bra and after that is
exporting your your yourself interests
into 96-well plate for downstream
singles out sequencing so here i'm going
to show you a little video of how
exactly each process takes place so the
penny is is where the the oep or the the
optoelectronic positioning system where
you can see as the little cages that's
identifying and directing single cells
into the nano pen or the little room or
i guess this is aggregating the
disaggregation that can be a tree about
the single cell level so each cell can
be directed in a single pen for a single
cell isolation so this is also a reason
why the import in is called penny as you
can see again the cells are being
identified and directed or being moved
into the bottom of the pants to achieve
single cell isolation and here the next
part is the essay so i'm going to play
the little video again for you and what
you see right here is the signal that's
being detected as what we call a
fluorescent bloom
we're so if you look at the the specific
path you're seeing the signal that's
generated or accumulated over time o
opening of each pen so what that means
is that at this particular pen you have
a plasma cell that's secreting antibody
of your interest and it's being detected
by your essays essays system over this
area or in a channel and the signal can
be very sensitive and also robust the
detection it can be done within minutes
and it's highly reliable because it's
it's basically taking a multiple time
points or data points over time and
again the multiplex assay can be
achieved by running multiple assays
sequentially or simultaneously and
lastly is exporting your yourself
interest for for abducts from sequencing
so what you can see right here is you
have the OE p or the optoelectronic
position and system exporting or
directing the cells out of the pen so
what you see right here is the movement
of the little plasma cell being directed
out of the depent into the channel where
it's gonna be flushed into a single or a
single well and a 96-well plate and the
plate can be stored on minus 80 before
sequencing so after introducing you to
the general workflow of how the system
works for for our single visa screening
platform you might
have some idea of why is the single
bezel screening faster and even more
robust with just one cell so just to
break it down for you and have it I have
a little comparison with the hybridoma
system or what you would do for you Isis
grainy so the medium the media volume
per pen or the Nano pen on the trip for
the screening for single visa is one
nano liter and if you have a total cell
total cell number as being one cell the
concentration for your for your
screening system is one cell per 1 nano
leader but your effective concentration
and here what I did is just to convert
the unit or the unit for my media volume
to one mil to get my effective
concentration which is equal to 10 to
the 6 cells per mil and if you compare
that to hybridoma where medium volume is
a hundred micro liter and the total cell
you need to examine or you need to wait
for to grow up is about 10 to the 10 to
the 4 cells per per well then your
concentration for that system is 10 to
the 4 cells per 100 micro liter which
equals 2 Tesla v cells per mil and you
can see right here there's actually a
tenfold increase in the single piece
house printing system compared to the
hybridoma system which means you have
increased robustness and also
sensitivity which is also tiny it saves
to your time for getting an assay of
readouts because first first of all you
don't have to wait for the cells to grow
up to a certain destiny to allow you to
detect your results and this means that
the single be so screening can be
detected or that assay can be can be did
you can generate the result within
minutes while hybrid or mode or Eliza
you have to wait four days to get your
results to summarize our platform
the only appear the optoelectronic
position and system is for the precise
movement or direction of single single
cell into into the nano pants or to
achieve single cell segregation and the
whole system is after you import the
cell is completely automated from from
importing screening to export and this
camera to use the chance to introduce
human arrow with less human handling
time and that also in the entire process
is recorded digitally for quality
control with both image and video and
the efficiency as we just shows you is
the screening for hybrid of much
typically takes about three months
because there is multiple rounds of
screening from the parental clone to the
subclone and you have to wait for the
cells to grow up but with single b-cell
the pro speed platform this whole
process can be done within a day or it
is essentially less than a day the
resolution and here what we mean by that
is to is the your ability to access the
vast to aunt but a repertoire at the
single cell skill which is about a
hundred fo or at least 100 foot increase
from from hybridoma because your fusion
is efficiency is typically one out of a
thousand B cells that can that can
actually form a hybridoma for you to
screen so at that step you are losing a
lot of the a lot of the B cells due to
the limitation of your fusion efficiency
and lastly the versatility and
flexibility this system can be used to
for in-depth characterization including
affinities specificity and functionality
for you peace out before you even
exported for or for C or sequency or
sequence e so to give you an overview of
the end what is screening process
against Kobe 19 if we're using the
hybrid Omar face display
system or the platform the initial
screen II will be will be used for the
target discovery or lead generation and
fall Astana is the lead identification
and optimization which can take weeks to
months and that includes characterizing
or validating the binding and blocking
activity using Eliza
or fax and characterizing the virus
neutralization in fact and here what we
developed is a pseudo virus system for
for Kobe 19 and next you have to you
have to validate that the virus
neutralization effect with the real Kobe
19 and follows that is that in vivo
functionality or animal studies before
you move on to the clinical study or to
even worry about develop ability so the
process is very arduous and very it's a
very long process but with pro speeds
single piece of screening we're we're
what we try to achieve is to combine the
initial screening the binding and
blocking activity and then also to to
loop for virus that or to look for and
body lead that has a neutralizing in
fact using the pseudo virus the kobe 19
pseudo virus system on chip or during
the screening process which can be done
with less than a day before we move on
to the identity or the optimization of
validation with the with the real kobe
19 and then also the the animal studies
so for the single visa screening we also
have been doing something a house and
but a discovery
we have screened for a total of six
hundred and thirteen binders and forth
within within those three hundred and
sixteen we were able to identify about
1993 by our binders i have a ligand
block in effect and with both of the
it's still the screening process is
still completed within one day and with
and here I'm I have a little schematic
to show you the experimental design at
how we just how we designers are
screening so essentially what you have
is we have our BD or the the receptor
binding domain of the s1 protein
conjugated to to to to a bead and the
beam is used to capture so the the
security antibody so if you have a
security and body that's specific to our
BD Pro are we need protein or the RVD s1
protein it won't be captured by the are
breeding bead and then you add a
fluorescent secondary antibody for the
detection of the correct a specificity
and for the ligand blocker I say what we
have is the target cell line that's over
expressing the h2 receptor which is
responsible for the interaction with
they are the virus and then the viral
entry and again if so if we have a
secreted antibody that's that has a
blocking in fact where we're trying to
what we trying to see right here is to
is is it's essentially a negative result
for for the RVD which is fluorescence
presently tagged on the stable cell
lines like that I mean if you have a
security antibody that can block the
interaction between the RBD or the
binding of the RVD and the our target
cell why we would not see the
fluorescence signal that's generated
from
RBD protein uh and here again you have
the secondary antibody that's used for
the detection of the secreted antibody
and what other assets that we're trying
to develop as the pseudo virus of the
Kobe 19 pseudo virus
I say this to Tobias is we what we have
right here is is to is to replace the
the envelope glycoprotein of went viral
vector by the Kobe 19 spike protein and
here what I'm showing you is some
activation data where we have different
doses of pseudo virus and you can see
the the luminescent signal from the
infected cells with different doses of
pseudo virus to verify the pseudo virus
infected the day of our target cell line
and we also have done a neutralization I
say where we have a positive positive
control or positive antibody that was
success that can't be used to
successfully block off the effect of via
the infective 'ti of pseudo virus so the
design of our experiment of approach
again in the schematic is showing that
instead of using a ligand or the our BT
protein or the ligand the RV or the
ligand for the X 2 which is the RVD or
as one protein we can replace that with
the the eg GFP expressing Kobe 19 pseudo
virus so the idea is that if you have an
antibody that's secreted from your
plasma cell or in premise of interest to
know to block the effect or to block the
pseudo virus in fact if ax T of the
target cell I then then we we can
identify a antibody with the
neutralizing effect so and this
experiment can be
on trip as well so aside from the
different assets that can be used to
develop antibodies against Kobe 19 we
can also accommodate different sample
species origin so what I interesting she
needs to do before as a chip our typical
workflow from EEMA immunized annual or
we can use transgenic animal for to save
downstream development time for
humanization or or other or other
related issues and what we do is to
harvest displaying the bone marrow that
lymph nodes depending on the the
immunization method and we enrich for
plasma cell and those subsets will be
directly used for screening but what we
can also do is to collect blood sample
from recover patient and isolate their
PBMC and those PBMC can either be used
to enrich for plasma cell that can be
used directly for screening or we can
enrich for memory b-cell which which
will culture for several days and for
Furby cell activation and with those
culture we can verify the Eliza positive
culture and which can be a pull together
for screening so from sample collection
or blood sample collection from recover
patient isolating PBMC to verified Eliza
positive culture for successful B cell
activation this process takes about
three to five days but this is
significantly shorter than the two to
eight weeks even as immunization process
no that's that's required for for our
for our workflow with them humanized
animals and here to present you some of
her newest results for human B cell
activation in single cell screening and
what you can see is that the
the B cell or B cells upset that we
enriched for from frozen PBF frozen
human PBMC and that a day one we're
screening or we're staining for the cd38
marker for for plasma cell for human
plasma cell or plasma blasts and at day
three you can see there's a significant
differentiation or expansion of the the
culture or the subsets that are that are
now seeing 38 positive and at day 5 you
have even a more even even greater
increase of that population and for this
particular test that we did I take 3 we
collected the sample and then a total
cell that we that we that we used for a
first screening was about 4 times 10 to
the 5th and the single B cell or that we
sorry the total cell that we collected
from the B cell activation culture is
about four times sensitive this and the
number of cells that we used for
screening for screening uh it's about
8,500 and among those we were able to
identify over 2000 or to 2200 that are
IgG positive
to summarize the chi-square proba
offers diverse functional leads against
Kobe 19 generated from different
platforms indicate including the human
eye even the love a naive for SD a
degeneration or the single domain by
degeneration and the pro spacing will be
cells granny and can't really accelerate
your Android a discovery because first
of all
rapid screen which can be done in less
than a day and it allows functional
assay during the initial screening phase
to save time and effort and also money
for your downstream undeveloped Deveaux
development process and lastly we can
provide the option to screen human B
cell from recover patients as well so
with that I would like to thank you for
for being here today and I'm going to
take some questions now so first of all
the first question is the number of
cells that are screened per chip for for
the screening is typically we do we have
different formats for the trip and then
the blend that has the largest largest
capacities and the 14k 14k chip which
has about 14,000
nano s and with that we can typically
pen or screen for 10,000 cells per chip
what is our sequencing success for
single cell sequencing right now we are
looking at what the single sequence is
not it's never a hundred percent
successful and right now we're looking
at anywhere from sixty to eighty percent
success rate is there any difference
between this between sequencing the
human B cell and wheat red transfer art
of the immunized animals the answer is
yes or no of course this is primers that
are going to be different because it's
different species but in terms of the
cDNA synthesis which is the most
critical stuff for single cell
sequencing the success rate is about the
same and then also the we are doing some
validation and optimization really
related to sequencing human be so but we
believe that the sequencing success may
even be a little bit high
then then transgenic or or especially
especially transgenic animals or a mouse
because this is a Syrian for human if
human VHDL sequences are even even more
conserved
thank you dr. Sean Taylor and dr. manzou
Kane for your informative presentation
as a reminder our speakers will follow
up with any questions you have submitted
via email following this webinar we
would also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor Jen script for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today and now
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of this
year 2020 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye